Prince area and Megan Markel made their
first official public appearance
together at the Invictus games last
September that was in Toronto the
sporting event created by Prince Harry
for when wounded troops is very close to
as hard as you may have heard since the
games began back in 2014 more than 1400
service members have participated they
come from more than 15 different
countries and the sports include things
like archery basketball and volleyball
Sir Keith Mills is the chairman of the
Invictus games and the Royal Foundation
and he joins us to discuss we welcome
you but I would like you to weigh on
weigh in as someone who knows Harry with
and without know do you think that he
will shave it off I'd be surprised but
we'll see what a surprise if if he
shaves it off no I think he'll probably
keep it on but hey he's getting married
and he's got a polices wife now right
yes because you're not they say keep
happy wife happy life
exactly so you're one of the few that
got an invitation what are you most
looking forward to tomorrow I think it's
gonna be spectacular I mean it's a
opportunity for the whole country to
solidify I guess the whole worlds are so
nice yeah but I think the atmosphere in
this country has just been growing all
week
every city every town every village got
the flags out they're having their
parties and tomorrow is going to be so
social yeah you know the Invictus games
going back to that for a second Harry
really was affected and decided to do
something after a flight from
Afghanistan when he was coming back home
right yeah tell us that story so I got a
call from Kensington Palace saying what
I go and have a coffee with Prince Harry
we'd recently come back from serving in
Afghanistan and had some very badly
injured troops in the transporter and he
followed their journey and knew through
that how difficult it was for these guys
to pick up their lives and put it back
together again and he came up with this
idea of a big international sports
competition I just finished doing the
London Olympic and Paralympic Games
helping put it together did you know
what it was about when they said would
you like to meet Prince Harry did you
have an idea who's going to talk about
that what did you think generally
speaking if you have a knight foot and
you get a call from the palace they
usually want to do something this is
what Harry said about you
he said when you're planning something
make sure you either got Sir Keith Mills
with you or don't bother at all so when
when you first heard about it you just
jumped at the opportunity I would
imagine whether it was such an amazing
cause and I went with Prince Harry to
one of the recuperation centres recovery
centers to watch these guys and sport
plays a huge part in their recovery and
the victors games now has impacted
thousands tens of thousands of wounded
guys run across the world how was it
having Megan there in Toronto and how
did that affect and change the
atmosphere well because it was the first
time that they'd been seen publicly
together and had you met her before that
no I met her subsequently but I haven't
been before that and you know when when
you've run something like a big sports
competition you want the spotlight to be
on the competitors on the guys that that
have served their country have been
wounded and are now competing in front
of millions of people and one of the
concerns that Prince Harry had and we
also be had was that spotlight had go on
then and not the competitors as it
happens I think it worked out really
well the Canadian Games are
fantastically successful and now we're
doing ready for the next one well let me
say you're the only one standing here
who actually knows Prince Harry
personally I'm curious about your
thoughts about him because for a while
he was considered party boy I think he's
long past that how do you describe him
as a man
yeah I think he has very strong values
in fact I think they both have very
strong values and those values are going
to be very important than as they as
they move through their life and you
know I think they both recognize they're
in a very special privileged position
and they really want to use that to
improve the lives of others and the
Royal Foundation which I also a chair
for Prince Harry and for Prince William
takes on lots and lots of different
challenges and over their lives that's
going to be a very important part of
what they do well sir Keith we thank you
for taking the time
joining us today enjoy the day tomorrow
we'll be looking for you in your morning
suit we'll be looking we'll be standing
right here wave when you go by thank you
so much